hey check out my fashion strapped inside
my jacket I just said a prayer for Baba
say let's go get active
geeking when they cash in
I just let the top down
show them that massive I pull up
freshers
I look like a manic dope inside my coat
got me so dumb
that I might need a nanny
let's focus on just those last two lines
again because he says I pull up freshers
I look like a man it could dope inside
my coat got me so dumb that I might need
a nanny so there's something almost
Freudian going on here I feel like I can
tell that young boy has been studying
some of the early 20th century
psychoanalysts applying their insights
to his own life here he is yearning for
the maternal you know he says I need a
nanny I need a mother figure a caretaker
this world's a great burden for me I
feel out of place vulnerable yeah at the
same time he realizes that he's fresh
you know he's even fresh and this is his
recognition of his own innocence and
this is really fascinating young boy
here is exploring the great tension of
Youth